los bomberos combaten el voraz incendio
que se desató en el bosque de la
provincia argentina de río negro en la
localidad de el bolsón la zona afectada
es montañosa y tiene algunos valles lo
que dificulta la extinción del fuego
estamos frente a condiciones extremas de
tiempo y combustible muy propicias para
la propagación y bueno se vio en el en
lo que lo que pudo afectar este incendio
desde la primera hora de ayer hasta la
última hora de la noche con condiciones
extremas
las llamas han arrasado más de 6.500
hectáreas en los alrededores de la
turística localidad cercana a la
patagonia y a la frontera con chile las
autoridades de río negro donde se
encuentra el bolsón dijeron que el
incendio se desató el domingo por
razones desconocidas y que es combatido
por varias decenas de bomberos uno de
los cuales sufrió heridas leves
lamentablemente ayer por las condiciones
en la que maroon dos casas la imagen que
en este momento hay 110 personas más o
menos trabajando en el terreno del cual
sumamos gente de parque de todos lados
así que más gente está trabajando en
lugar
varias provincias argentinas sufrieron
incendios en 2020 córdoba en el centro
del país fue la más afectada con unas
331 mil hectáreas quemadas en un año en
el que se destruyeron más de un millón
de hectáreas la falta de lluvias hizo de
2020 el año más seco desde 1995